what's up fool was so full podcast
what's up everybody what's up oh well
geo toys right here man all happy man
happy like here like 10 cookies myself
no I didn't but I what I hate a lot of
stuff lately no I just uh I've been
low-carbon ago no carbon it was so my
favorite sweater what do you mean no
this is wool it's very very itchy
without an undershirt whoa what so fool
everybody made you get miss Rodrigo's
birthday man we didn't say happy
birthday happy birthday man turn the big
on for my big four row v forty forty bro
welcome to the 40's a sir welcome to the
forty what's up that your president
brother birthday man well next time I'll
give you a hundred so I can give me
another one next time talk about drug
deals over the weekend over bro I know
trying to charge you do nothing tomorrow
by the way
sigh butcher pressing it up because I'm
gonna go to that thing to dog it's a lot
right those snakes yeah man oh yeah then
what's up everybody we're back man
what's up man oh I was talking to Lisa
no way over here man whoever have a lot
of meeting greets you know man man I
think my meeting we should be sponsored
by dentine bro standing in line bro
everybody gets a go artist worries about
having Gump and I smell there I worry
about my breasts inky and so should
everybody else I'm Elgin in a bathroom
yeah well happy but whose [ __ ] on you
smell like [ __ ] beer weed and ass be
edible teachers huh yeah man I'm
surprised that one night at the at the
club there's food like The Improv like
that's a lot of food for three eating
dog may be destroying nachos I see like
four buckets of Coronas and like for
nachos they're tearing it up bro oh yeah
I'm like that that table should be
called liability like beer and nachos I
could beer not your own comedy fan
mm-hmm I love bar food though I love
nachos and beer and mozzarella sticks
and all that stuff I love write
something new the other day bro Buffalo
hot we you know buffalo mozzarella
sticks so what's a buffalo sauce you
just come over like a mozzarella stick
that's been dipped in the buffalo sauce
yeah after after it's cooked sounds good
I used to dip my thriller I have to live
our mozzarella sticks
so terror month I had to burn my mouth
to remember at the SAC sandwich place
Ike she could get the sandwich with the
mozzarella sticks and say yeah Isaac
loves to get that do that is a bomb ass
bite right there our food was so full
man shout out to everybody in which
hooked us up at Fort Myers man actually
we're in Naples shut out - Hugo hooked
it up with the sticky right now the
state that has the best bud on the
travel gauge is Florida what dude wasn't
that bud great Florida on the road and
like you know cuz people come on to the
west coast
oh my god yeah do that but was good how
about the possible some people were
smoking with skinny blondes bro oh my
god Chuck I'm gonna let you dog
how about that I got ya bro I didn't
want to say nothin cuz it's be all I
[ __ ] Philippe is homies a little dick
dog [ __ ] diva I saw that fool holding
that rolling it up bro and I said okay
okay okay he's gonna cook that blood in
half and then we're gonna have a good at
blunt but now man he tells me all that
[ __ ] on that was on that blood and I
said whoa you still gonna roll it up you
just fold this and that fool just
there's some comics back in the day they
used to do a lot of those paper - blunts
but that's cuz you have gills yeah cuz
you have a little bit of weed but don't
even roll it I'll get us the exact food
I know man if your if your blood is
ain't fat don't show up bro I'm mad we
showing up with Dan like oh man I'll
save it for later don't invite us bro
it's bad enough trying to like you know
like you know get good bud but also it's
cooler they are skinny but they keep
bringing them I know like dude just like
one big old one put those six together
as one yeah let's get the party started
yeah skinny as paper
how would a skinny blood the skinny
joins from better than Chicago bro oh my
god that guy
don't throw skinny bro the rest in it
let the lollipops Oh little white steak
with a lollipop it's a full blow pop
it's a prison joyful so scary man tell
them about we're all gonna get high on
warble paper it's gonna hit it
what do that people mix with I'm saying
but I mean that'll be a diva dude but
you know I just smell good right dude I
kind of don't really like I don't want
to sound like a debug an or whatever but
I don't really like not smoking Louise
we're taking the kids to school right
first two rows right up at six
and I stood awake about 5:45 in [ __ ]
up my alarm at 6:00 and I got an earlier
alarm up around 5:45 6:30 but I get up
on that attempt you the restroom anyways
but like I said in a restaurant blow it
up for that forever then I go I play
with a rabbit forever laid down getting
paid for the rabbit then I go back to
sleep bro and then I wouldn't wake up to
a nine okay because you get fully awake
and then you go back to sleep now I feel
weak yeah two days in a row so what
happened after you to the kids at school
or nothing man like I'm about to go
ahead of Bowl and they're like we're
like ten minutes before we leave and
then like Lisa comes out with this white
with big-ass white bathroom bro bro for
smoking jacket you guys in the suite or
what don't forget the slippers you know
but info we don't look weird and
shitless she turn right douchey Here I
am bro worried about how I smell
I don't where's my pot and sure we have
shared our pan out I share the pacific
jacket she wears when she smokes yeah
it's not a robe it's a terry cloth robe
he'll back would like jackie onassis
[Laughter]
she's just chilling something you like
to do so so when she came back wrong I
told you the same thing bro I put on
this big old brown [ __ ] robe I have
she packing that she's ten years ago bro
that she was huge but like a 5x
Chewbacca's good strat bro that'd be
funny bro if I took that big bathroom
over to the public pool pretty much
turned brown it's not very good
yeah my like what hotel give you a robe
and slippers basically I found out later
on they don't give me the robe one thing
I'll say about bud though it's like when
people talk about their weed they say
this is the best way than you hit it and
it's not people should apologize for
this oh my god but to take for the court
people that we brought was two lights
red and green anybody listen man
oh my god you decide oh dude
but yeah Charlotte Hugo's in Mike yeah
Mike and a little teddy bear looking guy
yeah I don't know what his name is
though the name sir Camila legit oh and
also that although food I drove through
out of Miami one Michael Valley oh oh
yeah together works at Costco can it
look like you go a little bit yeah man
hey no yeah you go lady was there too
broad a man they were trying to invite
me over to their house she was although
she was kind of bustling yeah man we
could start a bonfire we could barbecue
we got a bunch of beer drinks we're all
here we take one bite everybody got a
6:30 a.m. fine and then she was sitting
down
oh the curb outside yeah then I said
look at her man she must she wants to
smoke though Frankenstein everybody she
was
and then I'm like a Hugo really said oh
my I'm looking for a nickname for that
the Frankenstein bro what's up fool
these days bars are right here I heard
you guys were you had a push ups contest
I did fifty three men
Oh was he cheating it looks like his
body's like leaving his leg dude like
it's leaving like stop working out so
much you're draining yourself Johnny hey
Satan by twos for the workout every
morning I leave man jogging and shake it
Chum get shot no way you're acting in
Florida dog food drugs all the way to
the beach and then forgot how to get
back to you back to knock in every door
[Laughter]
you guys watch the Super Bowl Carbone
listen to it right before oh that's
right you were home you came home they
know you go driving in a freeway listen
to it yeah we were watching at least
make some barmen nachos ok and close
song with hot dog oh that's what you
guys eat those ones or these are today's
this is today's sausage and egg army
sausage and cheese man [ __ ] I just had a
couple packs of them so Felipe's the
muse Catherine Brian
oh hell yeah dog he only responds to
captain captain even had my stroke
captain Brian inside of the club right
there and his crew and the wife is
welcome aboard when you're all calling
the family will you come to death dad
why the Admiral Lamar just sat there and
smiled the whole weekend she watched all
the shows on watched other shows you
sister bro really regulates she
sometimes she looks back with show
regret somebody fries beer
they're all like they're hardcore
Italian to dog food I had the lobster
bisque tonight I've had castle like
castle they had it Lobster yeah too
fatty to like like oily fatty in your
mouth it's Kissel like kissing for me
though no well yeah I'd probably like a
cheesy artichoke dip is somebody had him
that's what it looked like
okay so fun do you know it doesn't you
have to have the sterno and everything
it's a pain in the ass yeah it's regular
cheese so I'm gonna have to stay
hardened but yeah if you get those other
dips it's calm it's processed in some
way first time in Florida when it's not
hot to harmful Oh perfect
we are being beaten yeah man again we're
the how a three-bedroom house we made
some discoveries oh yeah she's gonna
have a kid
Oh another one
yeah man what's up fool man what's up
fool man did you get some rest of what
let me tell you man I'm the way back
home I slept like 1 hour 2 hours on the
plane
ah and when I got home I stood awake at
10:30 I fell asleep and I didn't get up
again till 10 o'clock in the morning the
next day I finally got like eight hours
of sleep dude was cool I was out slept a
little on the plane though I first the
older I get the more like sleeping bro
get him get ready to die dude if you're
lucky enough to go that way [ __ ] dude
what's up everybody
Oakland Oakland California February 11
that's this Saturday Paramount Theater
laff-fest
2008 Valentine's Day February 14 Corpus
Christi Texas American Bank Center with
Raymond Horta Brendon la Vella because
the Raiders are coming now
Raymond old I will be there also Rosie o
Tori's will be there too right yeah man
yeah you'll be there no more California
chachi Casino sold-out favorite 22nd
Last Vegas at the treasure islands
ticket or tickets to available February
23rd Rochester Washington at lucky ego
casino favorite 24th that show man do
not wait for the last minute for tickets
and be coming to that show because the
casino gives away a lot of tickets to
the VIP players of the show of the
casino so the only cell like around four
or five hundred tickets at a time so
that's the way it works at these casinos
the VIPs get and regulars get all the
free tickets and everybody else has to
pay so that's how it works at the casino
so don't wait too long to get your
tickets at the lucky ego casino favorite
24th also March 2nd that's right I'm
going to the big island
hello I hope it's the big island hello
I'm going there with
Rodrigo Torres yeah man and another
comedian to be announced later March 3rd
Honolulu Hawaii with Paul Rodriguez and
this woman Sarah was Reyes and/or Joe
Torre probably squeeze in there real
quick tonight in a teddy bear part of
genius my new nickname Bala Teddy Barry
what's up bro lose weight or [ __ ] it
nah dude I wasn't even trying to lose
weight to last month I've messed up my
ankle dude and I'm slowly getting back
into working out dude
lifting weights right now and I finally
did ten push-ups all the way and I'm
just doing I'm dude I'm just getting
back into the mix dude in slowly gonna
start jogging dude but I'm gonna do it
all fast
and I've been low carbing since my day
back was so full take this out bro
whatever the last time we were at the
nobel theater we I think we're I don't
know we're giving away a contest or
something you know and the person who
won was for San Francisco right and he
couldn't go mm-hmm right so he gave his
tickets away so now I'm coming back at
us with an oval theater March 23rd and
24th the full set a mess and last time I
couldn't go gonna eat them now you gave
them away dude tough toasties dude I
love that word dog I don't know call the
March of Dimes
you're killing me bania what's going on
we got we need the lease over here man
why would happen Hotel about that do
that one of the free tickets for the
show he couldn't go to this was like
three four or five years ago when it was
the last time we gave tickets away from
Nokia I don't even remember the last
time I gave tickets way for LA was a
long time ago he won tickets through
email and then he tells me he's from the
bay he lives in the bay and he can't
make it down and I was like oh well why
did you even participate okay
he hits me up two days ago hey you
probably won't remember me but I won
these tickets fact and I couldn't go cuz
I live in the bay
I don't remember you saying but I'd
really like to go and take you up on
those tickets like dude if you entered
the contest for LA and you're from the
bay that's the end of the contest you
don't you know if you can't make it it's
not these there's no rain check wanted
you to prorate them green check this
isn't a contest for the bay there's a
contest for LA back then can you imagine
like come on anyway hitting anybody
damn bro what up what happens every
punch oh did you watch a song ago I was
worried so I couldn't watch this is a
moment in this fool history the first
story right yes on this story so I'm not
there's no inside information or
anything but I was Punch amore had some
stomach cramps and I go to the hospital
hospital he's like maybe he he goes to
the hospital everybody's worried about
him and he's lying on the gurney there
and everything coming out coming out
from tasks and then afterward he goes
they go on a run to get his medicine
this is the story so he goes on a run to
get his medicine through the hospital he
and his wife so all you see the next
morning is his video of Chama Rita and
her hands and knees in her SUV with a
paper towels cleaning up they're
cleaning up the SUV and if you notice
they're kind of brownish but we found
the diamond so what happened was he said
well what happened was well I get
constipated I got constipated me because
I ate a lot of steaks and I got real
constipated and then so I took some
laxatives and it said take for maximum I
took ten he took ten laxatives he said
so right off
the hospital and seto hospital we went
to go get the medicine he said
everything let loose they finally kicked
in and he basically had a blowout in her
car amount to a horse yes I thought he
puked steam clean that muhfucka dog
that's like a steak for like 1984 in
there I do die I thought I found
chocolate in my dad's a medicine cabinet
what time I was like $7 like this [ __ ]
dawg
and I that should taste like mint dude
like three hours later I was like ah
dude she was coming down my leg my mom
start beating the [ __ ] out of me doc all
right lied I happen to be a picker
Street yeah she beat the [ __ ] out of me
dawg I took my ass outside took
everything off with the hose dawg yeah
I'm a [ __ ] right troppa troppa short for
tropical okay cool alright yeah yeah man
they're bad so this is just going on -
oh there it's over and this is brought
to us by con with the common ink their
little network okay I just seen it on IG
okay I guess we're gonna say okay done
those fools are bad dog [ __ ] each
other
and are they gonna debut that throw papa
he cuts on here first ever okay sweet
they're bad dude
yeah do so yeah you can't be eating 10x
likes to do ten roll and I've never like
I've only [ __ ] on myself
I'm coke bad coke tonight I did too much
bad coke and the next day for their bro
baby laxative they cut it with oh yeah
that was bad the other the worst party
coca ever done probably in a lot but you
know what Phillipe Brad think a lot of
that [ __ ] too is so cutback know what
I'm doing no more or less the guy that
I'm getting it from has a Lamborghini
but cuz I know his [ __ ] not gonna be
[ __ ] bro because I'm pretty sure a
guy that gives me a bump on the
Lamborghini if his [ __ ] in real he's
gonna kill someone in that club you know
I mean I ain't gonna yeah yeah man so a
babe in your lab yeah I'll do those
postures you guys make I like the
spaghetti we made dude that was bomb
with my homeboy what's happening I could
have told you through the part of
tropicale yeah one of these guys they
give my talk with - it's not spaghetti
if you get a chance to air BnB anywhere
man [ __ ] don't get a hotel man I know
there's seven you guys man yeah do you
have a full kitchen dude everything dude
I mean aids for mayonnaise pasta ya know
I haven't made pots in a while but I
like the pasta you may do I like the
meatball III peeled my avocado the way I
do it raw like I couldn't in half
did I make it a little squares then I
told that food is better this way we do
this way bro you don't get dirty and
then Johnny goes I let you put the whole
thing then I he peeled the whole thing
bro and ate it like a savage bro
it was juice flying everywhere Dawg get
jungle book man would you go inside
knows
so the whole points to be clean bro not
him
dude they didn't have knives at the
houses on this below they really married
our field me Robinson Caruso here so we
do it in El Monte what's up fool chillin
right oh hell yeah man I mean I love
learning bro me too doc I just wanna
know about my MC choke pants or least
it'll just stop like they're for
Halloween bro are you serious I'm
feeling like putting on sewage with a
brown stains in the back are you gonna
straighten your hair fool oh yeah fake
rings but exaggerating bro with them we
have a little mirror a little butterfly
Lisa Rita hangs over there bro dancing
dancing cholo friend was so full of my
acting class yesterday
Deb Lyman acting class if you have kids
that wanted to acting
Deb Lyman Deb lemon so Deb Deborah date
whatever man Deborah lemon look her up
and I was coming out her acting class
bro a bunch of kids who they're like a
kids class right after my class that's
everybody have a good I think classroom
i buy something to students say hello to
me then I was a go talk to his couple
this [ __ ] Joe from Fontana bro
for that acting class for their two
daughters one I want to be a comedian
like a soldier like a soldier so the
right there in Silverlake Bernardino
Silver Lake and so other right there by
that um that store that supermarket been
there gahafer
huh Gilson oh the old Ralph's ghost is
brought there by the I got the street
from mom I Rowena and I period there by
Marshall yeah right there by her period
and then I was talking to that couple
for a while and they were telling me
yeah man every Sunday they do it we
gotta be here three hours there Dean fun
to do he goes we don't wanna get stabbed
the round here oh yeah
you stabbed around here this is like a
good part of silver lace so for like 13
there's gay guys who drive by the do dry
bye bye bye anyway so I love that hanky
joke so gonna be careful out there
so I'll think about your joke they stab
you from behind
I'll stab you in the back so tell em how
much this neighborhood has changed and
how she Lea was in an early 70s when
they're all [ __ ] up with heroin I
don't know they couldn't believe it so I
was given a telling him our places to go
and have fun place to go eat you can
find you can spend three hours just walk
around sunset huh dude in Griffith Park
surround the corner right yeah but they
were staying like this yes on suture are
there those kind of wack and I got like
waiting for a tip everybody else was
plastic anyway so she uh I told him
where to go eat and all that good stuff
they couldn't believe it yeah they got
Chicago pizza where they're in Echo Park
and um she said well we don't got none
of that stuff where we live we have like
Little Caesars okay yo he don't [ __ ] you
bro yeah that's right there by hard
times pizza right r.i.p not there
anymore
yeah now it's a Jimmy John's or yeah oh
yeah where the best beats I ever had it
was really really really bad I never
forget we order it at La Grande before
they close we got three pizzas we had
everybody there man bean sauce and [ __ ]
a brother angel was there bro the last
time a fool kicked it fluffy was there
yes IVA cuellar myself my brother angel
this would be knee my kid for since I
was watching cable we were outside of
the studio and we're just poking around
all night remaining a first time we hung
out and we found out where our pot heads
I found out hey bro like weed I realized
we'd this were always like we
so what Bernie bro we went through a
whole age of Irish [ __ ] and then um my
brother you know in the crackhead life
when I smoked that [ __ ] to it to the
ends bro no he wanted look here's a
little Roach and that food said my
brother ain't Joe said everybody have
bean sauce like a pliers for the [ __ ]
roach and a gay bro was stoned he said
what somebody said pizza so I order
those pizza from their memory they angel
angel basil pasta so you have a little
couch outside on ya seat over the couch
bro okay do that [ __ ] away - yeah I had
a couch man and you know it didn't rain
all summer so I left it I'm starting to
porch you know like that it's a Porsche
ecology Summer of Love
Oh got hit up by Louie bro where I go
over there they say you're welcome to
come any time because they want you to
look at the roaches
[Laughter]
stop by and talk to Steven yeah no
Stevie no okay the guy with the beard
and he said that I'm not man that's for
roaches but yeah man well crawl it when
I was there bro dude we'll eat little
put it away right that - but the thing
is it's one of those old-ass buildings
in downtown LA there's a bunch of you
know water bugs rats - yeah you see them
you see the rat boxes even if you clean
that area they're gonna come back yeah
because I do the runs elevator sound
like chips
yeah Medoro see when you killed it on
that pop rocks yeah dude yeah after that
of course you'll be more well gonna come
whenever you want roach whispers so
you'll be like you believe bird crashes
Freddie if you ever get a chance man go
listen to our podcast guess Bert
Kreischer the [ __ ] machine a machine
man each other that story about him and
a friend [ __ ] doing below and then
their exterminator friend shows up and
that food was a little Bob and
let's to believe the whole pad that
guy's wife
what is this actual hairs tool in our
bedroom right now termites they'll hold
me master I'm hoping man you know like
you know everybody's doing their [ __ ] I
think he found out that their parting
and he shows up listen man I gotta pitch
here man but if you ever need like bug
spray oh I'll do it so that was a bumpy
and yes we turned a favor right away bro
yeah exterminating the house and in the
morning he don't give a [ __ ] service for
a sir comes back it tells you bro you
got termites what so fool my two sons
here bro
[Laughter]
families actually from Puebla which is
close oh really
we have the we have the comments for one
month bro I met these guys at chopper
Kalia man these guys were actually
they're fans of my comedy too but I saw
him when I got hooked up with that kind
of dead ass then from them I got to be a
bongo then I heard these fools
it was our eclectic bro are looking with
you in case you're double your words now
man but they're different matter awesome
and we got we [ __ ] hit it off a
tropical oh you were there yeah man so
what'd you think of the comments bro are
there bad is [ __ ] it but another they
have a newer band they're gonna be
called drop America bro dropping magic
where the hell you go from alright over
for me April give me I wanna be Pacheco
from East LA turn it yo me llamo Renee
Pacheco Rihanna diferencia entre las
voces nos the material universe say
universe say universe brothers oh yeah
three years apart
how come you straighten your hair bro
but when I when I comb it back and like
let it last you know like what strings
people they cover my generation bro ugly
but still confident bro what is it
called inconveniently unconventionally
attractive area I love that naturally
cute these guys broke so we grew up
right there and buy the Calvary Cemetery
against Danny where that big old yellow
crosses out on the 64 you little rebel
my first girlfriend to be right there
bro actually that actually she used to
live on Fifth Street or the Rowena all
right not even know what I did but a big
church is boring
never better that you just met there
yeah they make you bring your own books
there yeah antutu reading passages
that's the one I'm Beverly during the
right hand side are the one over there's
more more strict hmm so then one that's
really really straight thing like really
strict you gonna be ready Jess up knife
where am I gonna wear a dress is I don't
know what religion it is
oh the other one the one on journalist
yeah the gateway to heaven wife statute
of front-line to Lourdes
yes what is that religion is Jehovah
Witness yeah yeah well they got all
sorts of flexibility go there we live we
live down the street from there now I
have to go the girl the Jehovah Witness
bro she never Bobbie nothing for my
birthday
we broke up so you know we broke up
every morning she's knocking at my door
alright do you cover here bro no
comments yeah I did yeah went to high
school in a neighborhood now actually so
our parents were always scared convert
didn't show Leto so they sent us to
school using my grandma's address in
Montebello so we went to sure high
school
oh you went to the good Montebello high
school the Harvard on the hill
yeah my brother use my objective with a
marshal you know I hope that we turn in
we turn out getting into rock and roll
instead of a you know gang banging hell
yeah man totally into rock and roll man
in [ __ ] gangbanging school [ __ ] you
rockers yes in a movie yeah yeah no I
almost made the one of the little chubby
kid that gets blasted yeah oh [ __ ]
and we're moving that one what's the
ruckus so yeah I went through that
school right there yeah sure I school
and uh you know Samba with the pumper
mr. pump our math teacher no brother
yeah gee Papa gene pompa
your high school is the one that has
that they call our crash tub every
graduation to avoid drunk driving yeah
yeah right there we have it - yeah scary
ass boat oh yeah what time I was driving
all loaded bro not loaded but leaving I
slept in the parking lot while Quixote's
and I took the streets home and they
were drive through that Street we're
sure high school is hell yeah by Garvey
I guess to go home and in a day time
never been another [ __ ] date time
always been my time today I saw that
[ __ ] car brawl crashed up and wasn't
like a fake body inside I said don't
drink and drive
oh yeah man they were very tough about
it there then you have assemblies you
can serve it yeah yeah yeah you reenact
it for you where they they they live
like they do the whole crime scene
scenario they have a cop reenacted like
pulling out a bunch of bottles and
what's funny is that they have all sorts
of brands so I'm just wondering like
down that product place they have like
what is it not Red Ribbon Week but they
always do those campaigns cuz I remember
learning yeah so they have the drunk
driver and they have that guy from from
from world work world card drama doing
announcing ah here we go live at your
high school if you're gonna drink and
drive you're not gonna be alive because
they show you those videos
these guys just graduated 22.4 alcohol
now
gone forever there'll be no party where
they're going they're gonna be hanging
out with those Jehovah Witnesses see I
got a beauty in high school you're gonna
let the band we started right after high
school now we were never in marching
band or anything we never been like
musically trained like that we just I
see the lady right here uh-huh and you
know we actually just got into garage
music for a long time rock and roll
stuff and it was until later that we
started getting to more of the cumbia a
that sound norteña kind of vibe and he's
just like you know going back to your
roots and being proud of it like me like
a puss they're gonna say until now let's
take em oh I don't speak perfect English
but I also know speaks perfect Spanish
so just embrace both to this world and
entiendo
yeah book it dosent in I got into music
because growing up in high school I got
also into weed and so I didn't really
have a lot of places to smoke weed
especially not in my house so I would go
to shows and then I would go to my
brother's practices to smoke weed and
then as I was just around the whole time
I kind of started growing into it
started picking up in admiration for the
drums because prior to that my brother
and I were always jamming out but really
like it was marijuana that helped me get
into music that was my gateway to heaven
right there in East LA hell yeah I was a
good weed though it was some of that
some of that Indo the Pretender a
pretender right before right before the
cush era where Pretender was still Bom
that's we're talking about one that went
people want to do want to smoke with us
after after the show and they like they
have a big bag of weed and the ruling of
the the Swisher sweet but like like
let's wish your sweet dough they match
the with the amount of weed they have in
that bag it's the way that a little
sprinkle sprinkle a you know the four of
us write little line of weed whenever
you want to get tight Broly we're we're
by your backstage smoke everything now
blood is going to grow crisis smoke
everything your backstage you should be
smoking everything's wrong dude I don't
want to sound like I'm in your backstage
you shouldn't be smoking that [ __ ]
should be going all out dawg you should
invite it again
the words I'm trying to make this laughs
shouldn't come out of your mouth right
there boys when you get picked up at my
throat and get kicked out
[Laughter]
we had a comedian Chicago brother fool
but skinny ass joint and then he broke
it in half and say that's motive for
later
never again that's against the rules
right the death wish I don't even read
anywhere breath the rules right
especially with weed because you can't
be tight with weed dog if you're gonna
puff you're gonna [ __ ] puff girl you
wanna get [ __ ] stoned like Lisa bro
she could never show to a party brother
bring over backward with one get one
grabbing it do people are gonna be
freaking out and there'll be some girl
on the couch going oh my god there are
brown for the [ __ ] [ __ ] woody no
Joe does I think a grande blunt is a
perfect or how about I do it that shows
that with backwoods dressed up with a
backwoods gear but has no weed yeah he's
like the Red Bull girls shows up with a
product it was that full really from the
backwards company or he just made that
little jumpsuit he live in the backwoods
what's up fool so how do I get started
in a band when you get how many but I'm
gonna been here been into before this
one we chat our own band before we
started playing when we blew these
little Junior's and I was more like
skinny jeans indie music David Martinez
babe no we started playing we were
little kids
our grandma we were always seeing
baterry Mendel's you know causing
trouble and stuff and so my grandma she
she's like she grounded us she put us in
the garage and locked the door with the
lights off and you know when she went
outside we turn on the lights and I had
a guitar and it was all out of tune but
you know I was like [ __ ] it let's play
and then Renee got some some like some
spoons and got my grandma's like a pot
where they make the moly the ceramic so
it's like one of those expensive Molly
pots and he ended up playing it too hard
and then bro
until my granddaughter aking is
moralistic ever like oh let him only and
they got mad but we were like hey that's
cool yeah and we continued it on with
our uncle who always had instruments
laying around his house so we would go
to his house and jam out there just
because you know he had access to
everything amps mics speakers drums
yeah he was he was an interesting
character perky when we started playing
cumbia music he was like he's like my
dad you know he was really happy he's
like a my sons are playing cumbia music
cuz he plays in a North Indian group and
so my uncle's like oh yeah well let me
hear one of your songs
so I playing one of my songs right and
I'm singing it I'm doing my thing
and so as soon as I finish it he just
kind of like looks at me in disapproval
cumbia no se toca el nombre la cumbia
like we give him to be a bad name for
get back yeah like it's like smashing
you know and and you know actually that
really helped us because we were like
well that's actually not a bad thing you
know that we're changing something
traditional like cumbia into what we do
it within now and the surprising thing
is um after tropical like he was like
really proud of us he said man you guys
met los Tigres in norte and now he
believes hey let me get backstage and
bring the gram
what's the biggest show ever
biggest show is Coachella oh you guys
play catch and yeah we do Coachella last
year which was pretty what stage the new
stage that they built another stage yeah
so that was cool it was but I mean
that's like a weird trip though because
I don't go to Coachella and it's on my
thing you know it's like after the first
week so I leave a little sad oh it was
like Disneyland you can be all but dude
all those people sleeping on the side
all musty and steel pretty people with
her oh that's a first day in the first
couple hours
your third your third your third date
trans performances windy rule there's
they have suites on the outside
your hotels oh yeah there's some scene I
mean going that there as an artist was
pretty nice right right driven around
everywhere nice but only on the day of
that you're playing after there's a
swingers yeah yeah the first night I
went there
we took acid and and you guys did oh
yeah
and so we watch your Radiohead right and
then uh radio headset which is like
butchered because you kidding the bass
was like going off they were having
sound problems and then they still went
through their whole like hour and a half
set with like problems and people were
leaving leaving and like all these a
rich spoiled kids white kids they're
like what's going on like why did this
sound like this like don't worry it's
gonna be better because they're like
tripping hard and I never got better
yeah I didn't get better at all until
they played creep creep was really good
and I was like oh this was worth the
wait and and then they kept playing more
and it just kept talking shitty and
shitty and I'm like I'm going down with
the ship you know like are like
philosophical acid moment that was a
trip because I don't know how to get out
of there and I'm like how do I get out
of this place because it's so big like
the song was bad like them but then I
complain no you get in here cuz they're
just perfect cuz their monitors you
could hear it it sounded like somebody
had it like a messed up aux cord you
know like they're played and then
everything was a Thom Yorke was like the
whole crew was gonna be fired and he
said we got visitors from aliens that's
a pretty good rate of headroom right
yeah so what oh the song that I'm
trouble Kalia therapy Kalia
oh they treat you well for the first
hour bro your card in an hour
oh my god the first address ruled only
go for three hours
yeah right yeah it was a short amount of
time it was yeah I mean I don't know
what they cheaped out on getting good
sound people or something because
they're for the first three songs you
can hear vocals during her set but you
know we had it we had a pinata though
and I was [ __ ] that baked we uh we
got the pinata during one of the songs
tossed it up but Renee pitched it to me
so he got off his drum set pitched it to
me and then with my guitar just swung it
into the audience and it broke into a
bunch of pieces do you have candy yeah
my son told me a lot of good chocolate
rubber caviar oh I only had one taco and
you gave me that day I see the [ __ ]
lines dude yeah he's like wait right
here don't go and like all right he like
turns back with the plate like once I go
in there it's like what was it yeah it's
fine he came in walked with a crowd it
was so many people show by Kalia
we're walking behind the tacos - yeah
dude figure out a little route I think
the most surreal moment - is that me and
los Tigres oh that's right we all were
together yeah that was intense man yeah
I was on acid so I was like are you
serious it's badass to see you Mike up
close and [ __ ] they're super nice and
they're all like clean-cut for their
weight in Boots
needing a living cut out is it wasn't
their backstage like on [ __ ] it just
sealed up nobody
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah okay the main stage was chaotic
dude everybody was furious but
snowflakes complain about the show first
it was cool we played early so we're
just like joining the whole thing just
he Britain would yeah and he still got
it man still got the charisma yeah I
think the homie borrowed Andy from Boyle
Heights that food was the one that
styled them up so what school do you
think you like your big break we just
said while we're getting gays we're not
doing mom we're not doing with these
[ __ ] gays at Sheridan anymore punk
shows attorney styling I am in the truth
that's where we would go get stone and
those two bro you when I was in high
school man yeah they still going to
Houston militia yeah yeah Skaar punk
scene in South Central
yeah the punk scene in South Central was
around when I was around in East LA we
do a dorm at Hoover Park yeah they still
do more there's bigger the big scene
know who the show's been discussing
still big you get a big house and it
gets packed you know four or five
hundred people come through in a little
bit all these little liable these cop
out you never heard of her yeah and then
some of them you get some of the bigger
ones that break out but you can't really
escape the scoffs you know and go into
like play something different because
you're stuck in that genre
which is kind of like what happened with
the Commons you know you're the comments
which is like psychedelic cumbia punks
it was always this kind of this thing
like oh they're a punk band and so come
on get did they treat you a little bit
different because you're like Oh Punk
it's not really like a professional band
you know and so we're trying Americ band
oh yeah there to go Raji yeah exactly in
some ways Susitna Sarah onion they have
long hair
they look like Felipe's sons but yeah
what would would've worked out for us
was definitely Coachella that got a
sluggard press and we got a lot of
better gigs we came out in the LA Times
and the front page with little corner
like 7-eleven pick one up and I tell the
guy that's right behind me didn't even
know hey that's me right here look check
this out stop reading it Oh Lady Anne
Oxnard dog Sonata paid for that she
paper I started reading you right there
for the character I think that by 78
buzzing they're [ __ ] mean as lady no
I'm one of the ladies in Mexico the
charge there I did fart in there would
have been like one of the best show that
one of the best days before for you guys
to wear to perform yeah we did nine on
Broadway last year right there on fit in
so they closed down all of Broadway and
we did one of the the street shows fifth
and spring and that was insane man
dialect I like the whole block was full
and you know bunch a bunch of yeah that
night I was on mushrooms right before
performing just went up and just like an
ocean of heads
that was crazy yeah because it was
packed and then the whole the whole
street is closed down so do we [ __ ]
over here bro no he's actually just
started with that drop America plane
this is Brandon over here come say hi
Brandon he's from East LA to LA man
that's funny man we were talking one of
my Twitter posts today was my family
said that I got to Hollywood I said nah
man you guys stood ghetto one of the
courts was he thing is all bad cousin
live them on a battle now Eastern a
Boyle Heights if you want to buy the
battle you've made it yeah and if you
live with a mother bellow and somebody
from East LA moved into your
neighborhood you live in a bad
neighborhood now yeah that's what you
gotta move to Pico yeah man if anybody
everybody in the other side of
Washington is to the best of my rabello
but he mother was just call this to your
converse we're all the statement we all
shut about the Citadel during Christmas
was so full so yeah we're getting yeah
we're getting um typecast as a better
punk alternative banner well yeah you
know like a punk cumbia ban and you also
have outlandish outfit like those type
of bands that I've seen before yeah so
we just um I mean we've been a
three-piece for so long and I mean we
got that formula down so we're like hey
we want to add another guitarist at a
piano add like just expand on the sound
make it a bigger sound look yeah you
know just progression in its progression
yeah yeah and in the music industry
though people are very weary is that
because it's a it's what they call
branding you know we have to rebrand
everything now and so yeah like our
manager decided to not work with us
anymore the booking agent I mean and
we're in a career yeah after we all the
great story start like this broads
believe me you know we're grabbing
nominating to ban so yeah right now it's
just like oh yeah they're doing this
full-time drop America focusing on a
grind well like the label say or the
managers they are the blue they just
were they just said there was going to
be too much work for them to handle the
transition and that it's a whole new
Instagram page Twitter page with new
followers yeah I mean we're just gonna
change the handles it really wasn't as
dramatic is like it's so so they were
[ __ ] tripping on you guys opposed to
even like fans tripping on you guys yeah
the fans are actually a lot more
receptive there they're excited because
it's still Renee and I'm writing the
songs but when more members and it just
sounds bigger and better yeah but those
fools like your managers they don't know
what's cracking on the streets are none
of that [ __ ] on yeah I mean it's good
the managers bryggen agents they take
risk but they don't take the biggest
risk you know the artist always takes
the biggest risk and so the booking
agent was like you know at least we hear
that on good terms he's like hey you
know keep us updated of how your career
is going and then down the line I said
what you guys making money then we'll
work with you why'd you guys change the
over to well I mean the comedy Commons
doesn't really sound like a Latino
Beneteau it sounds like you're what does
it sound like Philly business the
Commons even some white boys from
Tribeca and it was a trip because we
went to Mexico we hadn't been there in
20 years and we coleman's let's comment
those good mornings you know we went to
Mexico and we were talking with their
families like oh what do you guys do out
there were over were musicians what's
the name of your band and then we you
know trying to say that they're like a
what you know into us that was kind of
like embarrassing too and we're just
like you know we just gotta embrace
don't let the you know medicine give it
a good name throw up on my heat gun are
you guys gonna bring all the common
songs over with you guys some of them
some of them we're gonna transition
you just you know we gotta grow out of
it too and then some of those songs are
still didn't let's we still have I know
sis how so plugging yeah
what is your nature for drop out my car
drop my car led be show is on March 24th
at the smell no and we've been there
before
now was the whole time it's a DIY space
in in downtown LA it's like a 8 p.m.
it's gonna be cool we're gonna we're
gonna hire north in your band and
they're gonna we're gonna have them
covered Shelley no Sencha songs
competition you know all the classics in
we're gonna have a dance competition to
see a good dance warranty and you know
those fools were getting down over there
to Sandow this whole [ __ ] put some
old-ass man do this muhfucka had to be
like 80 dog ripping up that dance floor
in his little suit and his little boots
with a white ostrich yeah little hat to
the side into the pointy ones off the
bed scratches I do instrument to the
best six to apartment this is a
12-string I got there at a thrift store
and that's out it sounds beautiful man
does that play like a guitar or no right
it's tuned like a guitar the same way
different strings right see I mean you
could play if you didn't have all the
strings you could still play with
regular strings and it just gives it
more of a bigger sound I've been writing
a lot of the new songs with this because
I'm gonna play that too yeah what's the
difference between that and a guitar
fool big hurts
that's what the tigress I get DVDs do
them what Lisa said to describe your
sound Denise and news a new crop America
start to get an atom or a keyboard yeah
yesterday actually yesterday we had a
phone interview phone meeting with
potential booking agency who wants to
work with this they do this festival
called desert days and in Joshua Tree
lastly they booked like Iggy Pop did you
before that they got Primus and and it
was a good conversation with good
meeting and we might be working with
them and but they described our sound
they were like a union music sounds more
Castro it's not Critics Choice Awards
over here or country cinematic but with
the the Latino Mexican twist you know
because that's I still sing in Spanish
and I'm it's something that I want to
keep doing because it's essential you
know [ __ ] Spanish is being you know
replace so much with Spanglish and it's
fine but yeah you know it's like I feel
it's a sort of discipline to be
religious some of the we're trying it
without saying like mixing in words and
in English because you don't know and
it's better just to ask you know where
Mexico I would always think mostly just
about it you know asking asking is
because you know just got it to me I
mean I was formerly an English teacher
before doing this full time I was
teaching an English literature for two
and a half years with like 17 to 24 year
olds kids a dropped out of high school
okay I was working with them and I was
pretty crazy maestro yeah they call me
mr. Pacheco do mister they say mister
mister or one of them came up with
because my last batch echo or both of
our last and you get no Pacheco means in
Spanish Mexico no but check with me it's
just so you usually say oh it's the
staff in Pacheco he doesn't mean I mean
Pacheco which means they look really fun
in stone and so we got to the airport
the security inspectors really easy see
stammering but check oh we're just like
190 enemy we just got here
entry denied just a minute the hanukkah
[Laughter]
[Music]
shipping good with Mexico I what I
what's going on is some fools are good
they got money are grown at themselves
now but fools the only way fools would
get kind but over there was a fool that
came over here yeah yeah they groped
themselves the friend of ours had let me
try some of his desk because I had mine
like swag yeah stuff and yeah its tone
is like people grow it and that's how
you get your good stuff down there
rather wise you buy it out sir oh yeah
influences growing up musically yes well
it rain so when we grew up we listen to
like you know obviously what our parents
listened to so kind when you go to a
birthday party or something you hear I'm
not my chose you know if I can promise
to Connie's Bronco dealers in North II
like you know all those classics and for
me it wasn't it - I was like an
intermediate school that had got into
rock and roll music because we would
always just listen to that was at the
parties or you know we used to listen to
Radio Disney so we were listening to
that Backstreet Boys NSYNC were little
kids you know Britney Spears and but I
remember this one time we had a
homecoming choke at her 7th grade for
the basketball team and they had like a
little pep rally and there was a DJ
and adidas started playing the song and
it sounded better
no I was there it was a rock and roll
song and he was like you knew that he
would be true you know and and and doors
were that I would always see people with
the this misfits culture you know and I
was like you know that sounds like it
would be the misfits cuz it's kind of
deathly sounding and so I asked my
friends like 'hey is this the misfits
plane right no no no this is [ __ ] the
doors bro and I'm just like [ __ ] all
right went to the library got a door CD
in you know but yeah that's where it
started for rock and roll yeah man just
like being told like nah dude this is
not useles broke your mommy just like my
mom and my mom she's like oh yeah yeah
mom kind of just got me into that she's
to listen to a lot of rock and roll
because she came to us she was born and
mccauley and you know like the front
there so they always have like a lot of
it like I used to love that [ __ ] with a
rock and roll safety song Bureau supper
son Bobby does nothing to me anymore I
mean we we unfortunately never got into
that be Leo Don [ __ ] oh yeah John
kouko-san cheese cousin Fred owe him a
nice building fancy those are all
classic wake us what yellows makers just
come in aunty
like a little square took a little too
many Oh in case you forget yeah
yeah man it's um I mean our parents they
came here to to us like in the 80 so
they were already like in like late
teens like you know early 20s and so we
our parents never showed us like the
Beatles or you know old these Chicano
old decent stuff so we had to like go
back and do our research and like
literally like I would go to work at a
library before doing teaching and and so
I would just always stayed in the music
section reading books and like looking
at Chicano history rock'n'roll and
listening to all those classics then I
found out about sound of shattering the
Pharaohs and no question mark in the
mysterion's ritchie valens
research you know which just the other
day no it was a day that means the day
music that supposedly was obvious who
didn't base that's what that's what they
want you to deposit wasn't it snowing
yeah it's too crazy to drive to the
plane cancel the gig are we basing it on
the movie one man you came into the
showing up a motor-b that I'll just hire
a private jet out of the blue how there
were no Tara check the agent no one that
wow that other one took off that one
time oh yeah shoot up in the sky all
crazy I thought that flight from Tucson
a little bit of courage it was my second
time a private jet with Mike Epps and
man that [ __ ] played like you know a
normal plane it's fat it's heavy
a lot of bad food on it
it takes its time going up there the
[ __ ] shot like a rocket dog hey
how did it so we're like one of those
one of those dragons of Game of Thrones
oh they couldn't get a gas mask - I can
fly this place just cries we had to
drive everywhere we did we did it was
like a two-month - or 52 days all over
the US and [ __ ] driving everywhere in
a van you know it wasn't always like
this
we're in India we before [ __ ]
tractor-trailer that broadly gig dog it
was hot as [ __ ] good talk they have all
the chocolate we can eat we're in India
yeah what's so fool with a fool boy in a
restroom break down it right now he's
gonna go take a DAB how do you describe
your sound I mean I posted like what all
right so what my idea was you guys sort
of John Sebastian you know yeah it was
more akin romantic oh you know but like
his early stuff could John Sebastian he
has a unique way of writing he writes in
a lot of money buddy so he writes in a
lot of minor chord progressions so for
example that's a D major a it sounds
happy but soon as you put the matter
gives it a whole different earring is
which is like with the doors worked with
too which is those minor chord
progressions those 7th
I mean it's every musician you listen to
this it makes sense but he had a lot of
these songs that like for example
they're more it's a good more yeah sort
of like that but that's more when he got
more popular right the older stuff like
a stock a meniscus or veinticinco Rosa
what got him famous
yeah those early stuff and to me that
was a it became evident that style it's
kind of like a gypsy style you guys
heard of ETP off yeah the French singer
she has that same kind of like good
gypsy knees to it so it's like combining
juncture Ostia and eat it Piaf you guys
know django reinhardt the guy that
played with three fingers so it's
combining that gypsy nice with the
tropical cumbia sound we really happy
I'm gonna do it again do it again
[Laughter]
no bongos and we have another guitar in
the car so we make sure it's coming up
March 24th right the first official show
with drop America in Los Angeles we're
gonna find you at right now just through
our soundcloud page and then but for the
most part with everything that we have
with the comments as soon as the last
show June February 27th we're gonna
switch all those handles to drop on
Mejia alright tonight right
[Music]
tonight yeah I know so mad you heard I
was just you and your brother or other
heads just him and I for the most part
we Easter's we used to do a two-piece
and I would play with the Loop Station
yeah we once we would do generator shows
like um you know like get those power
converters so it's like a little car
battery and you plug it into this
machine and you can plug in your guitar
amps we would do that and just go bust
get we did that outside the pixi show in
2000 and what is it 2010 we're at the
Palladium yeah at the Palladium we did
it outside of it because it was a
sold-out show and we knew there was
gonna be a crowd so we where did it but
I mean we're learning we didn't even
have stickers we didn't have CDs or
anything so it was just like for us just
to prove it to ourselves like we can't
do it didn't try to kick you guys off
security got everything worked out
perfectly it was very serendipitous a
dad like that holy moment feel like
where the clouds just opened up just for
you and then like it was crazy because
when we did it we played it nobody was
there parking was open everyone was
waiting we performed we did and then we
left and like when we went to go do a
u-turn Mike came back like five minutes
afterwards we just see like everything's
packed all the cars are filled and it
was like like that never existed so very
weird and I had a very ecstasy feeling
with you know cuz we proved it to
ourselves it was almost like jumping off
a cliff big ego feels snug into a lot of
concerts have you I think yeah I snuck
into FY FS when it was still like easy
to do
oh really yeah how did you do it you
just walking through the side you just
walk all the way down to the gay tents
and you just come in just climbed it was
funny cuz there was a with Rizzo and
Johnny Battaglia there was a dude that
said Oh Don Felipe trouble to get on or
the list you said
sneaking with going with you guys we
don't have a ticket I told that fool
exactly how to do it cuz I had a pass
but I were just sneaking in and out just
to see if I could and he'd even follow
me though did you tell him I told him
exactly to do just follow me go this way
Oh
but I he was too scared and like he
looked he was like a pressed dude he
wanted an interview or some [ __ ]
he's the chicken Gus is it was an
interview but they're no press pass you
were supposed to have something firm in
the front okay
I stroked it to Dodger Stadium man I
would like to do that dog I went all the
way bro with the warehouse people are
out bro just walking there like I belong
be a little blue polo I think you could
do it yeah to the look-around brothers
pigs [ __ ] I'll be with power through
power yeah well you snuck it to fi fi
you uh you did it by yourself or with
people yeah I was a group of us but it
was like everyone for yourself yeah I
have heard of it I saw a video this guy
who snuck into a Super Bowl right yeah
just a ladder
and he didn't even use it to climb over
he they were just carrying it yeah it
was a couple guys at one it was like
three of them they end up getting kicked
out naughty God they were in they were
just was so fool and funny man even even
if he had performed at the tropicale
yeah you're walking around and father
he's still stuck in those places where a
man they were stopping you know after a
while I see through an uproar every but
they cleared that [ __ ] man only friends
and family could be there yeah man the
only time I've ever seen the [ __ ]
forged clear black stages from Metallica
yeah those guys when we Melos degrees it
was crazy because we had so we perform
after I said a tropical area we did our
set and then this big-ass dude he comes
up to me like super intimidating looking
to Wayne 'fl Duane yeah yeah therefore
he's a he's a he's a you guys in the
comments and I'm like yeah what's up no
you say you guys came out in Long Beach
pressing you guys were talking about los
Tigres who said that
oh my gosh
it was all of us he was like he's like
hey whoa I really like what you guys
said about all Stieglitz and I died I
was really cool and so then you know my
my thinking cap went on I'm like hey
well can we meet those dudes in there
like week that out but then come 9
o'clock you know where you guys that you
guys are supposed to be here right now
yeah yeah and you're right because when
we played Coachella even though
everything was like like we were in the
parking lot when everybody was being
taken out and we were walking to the
parking lot every single moment like I
saw flashing lights cuz there's a lot of
cups I constantly felt like I didn't
belong there I was like all for them to
kick me out so it was weird you know I'm
not used to that like meeting a fan man
yeah what's up fool of giro my right
here right here right here chillin you
know join a banner jingle I always
wanted to be in a band that's why
because nobody's jobs and careers and
harbour fright for what 99 cents
everybody that works at home people be
there are another bad
don't pay the song you want to play
they'll throw him at you dog where's all
the chicks bro
there was chick on a bat member without
food I mean II bought the bunch of
chicks now we're hanging out with two
fat dudes right now a lot of dudes yeah
it varies man you're very sometimes you
know don't [ __ ] leave what a battle
bro whatever you do now sometimes it's
crazy like you know it happens and
sometimes it doesn't you're just like I
mean when we were performing we're
working you know that's our job so that
happens it's secondary it's not really
like that's the way the sound if you
don't really want it when you really
want it yeah hello you better come along
and [ __ ]
you like Billy Bob bars Barker
all right sparking a scene from fight of
the Condors hey bro leave you alone bro
I'm trying to play the lonely guy over
here happy [ __ ] load that show man I
could see you guys having a show like
that man that's a big fat side of the
Condor I could see you do concrete
concrete Conchords whatever condors I'm
not sure bro you know they're wrong I
spoke to them before the show I guess
other jiggered managers
[Music]
young man was so fool using a manager
that wasn't the worst had a [ __ ]
department store like well gee Joe
manager boy a flood of the Conchords do
I have never watch never I would have
watch you know what I did watch was uh
the vampire movie looking brilliant what
we're doing darkness hilarious the
leader of the wolves is the manager of
the flood and the show are you serious
okay
and they're all drawn from the
connecting they're all homies right it's
hilarious bro there's a show he's pissed
off at the boy at both of the guys
Jermaine the other one and he brings it
with office for when you realize that
he's not really is awful brave voice at
a travel agency he goes a little bit
come to talk to you about your
performances actually which is they're
doing okay by the way I got you I got
you another around larger my show
he's a whack show bro we're talking
about our friendship right here your
friendship with fading right now we're
right now we're uh we started off as
buds you know as mates so now we have a
cool flavor man
yeah TV show there are some pretty
catchy songs from New Zealand New
Zealand bro were so full but that moving
tell everybody what a good movie matter
what we do in darkness yeah I've seen it
three times
what we're doing shadows funky I wish
you'd get a hold of Philippe I couldn't
find a [ __ ] more you talking about me
boy my birthday's coming up June 11 if
anybody can get a hold of a fresh copy
of smiley face look out for it you still
haven't found it no no brought some we
were Anna Faris how badass movie yeah on
YouTube it's on there for sure yeah I
just looked up stoner movies cuz I was
looking for something you know the part
that killed me is what do you like all I
can deliver that shakes you doesn't know
I suppose no taking a shower jerk it off
it's like everybody [ __ ] eight-by-ten
bro
remind us what the audition scene was
what's black and white it's like a
comedy a buddies were like she's super
store right and the characters supposed
to be like hey how you doing Frank hey
Frank how you doing Frank
all our bro and then every time she get
more [ __ ] up she has to restart her
to-do lists bro
I only seen that movie once too but that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] fine we're so full so
now bro we're gonna have a special treat
bro [ __ ] yeah dude drop a mic out here
bro they're gonna play for us the world
premiere acoustic versions I don't want
the way right push it back a little if
you want those mics
[Music]
like there
Damas Y Caballeros aqui por primera vez
in in what's up for podcast from Felipe
Spicer's de Santander
[Music]
the sound we represent is a Elysee Roma
so this song I'll just remind you guys
know you can see the Godfather
yeah so the guy that wrote the
soundtrack freedom they made a
compilation in it's on YouTube it's
called a Lazaro man it's a a bunch of
his like original soundtracks but it's
like these weird songs in and I love
that soundtrack it's caught it so I
named the song after that
[Music]
Stan you need us buddy this for feet
your feet soon
you
[Music]
we'll extend your boy
yeah man was so with that with tight
broke oh yeah man like it remind me of
some old school Leonard Cohen bro oh
yeah actually when he passed away and
when he passed away dad a bunch of
ex-girlfriend's texted me cuz like a lot
of my girlfriend's I show him Leonard
Cohen and so they they were all like hey
I'm sorry for your loss like he was like
me relatively it was he's good a good
singer you can't even like it like it's
a good good song and a good sound
killing it over there on that [ __ ]
guitar by the way thank you and yeah I
love it bro oh [ __ ] yeah I am throw up
on my he got fat now alright I want I
can't wait to see we got some treats in
the car you guys want one yeah where I
can't just he was next what you think
Lisa yeah it's different it's different
but the scene when I hear the full band
on Soundcloud I listen to all of the
tracks and to me it feels like Robert
Rodriguez movie soundtrack or Quentin
Tarantino soundtrack sort of thing you
know like that kind of you know the
bangbang song that Nancy Sinatra does in
the beginning of yeah that's what it
feels like a lot of that about hitting
them up
Oh
[Music]
I do recall command commander Cohen he
was I remember you well hotel Oh
Marianne yeah what's up what's up fool
we got drop America for many of the
common people
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys for having us